mark Normand you're gonna be into Gotham
this weekend almost sold out we're right
there oh let's do it all right yeah go
see mark this weekend at Texas Jerry I
said hey you want to pop in he said
who's this have you been talking to
okay so the relationship is still strong
how about this tell me maybe I shouldn't
leak and you should all right
who knows what he's hearing anymore I
was actually thinking about you last
night because I was watching the B movie
my son loves the B movie and I was
watching it and I thought to myself if
he was making this movie now mark would
be a B I would be a sunflower or a
mosquito or something because he put all
his friends in it you know the guy who
played putty is has a big role in it
yeah and I mean the only reason that
putty is in this movie is because of
Seinfeld right and then that's when I
met him made me think mark Normand would
be and b-movie put me not be the guy the
one bug carrying the swine flu or some
[ __ ] yeah he'd [ __ ] with me a little
buddy gonna leak what's that
what are you gonna leak and it's been a
while so I really you know put some
thought into it a lot of rewrites a lot
of edits and I said blah blah blah I
hope you're good and he goes oh I was
just talking about you today it was like
oh this cousin kid is a piece of garbage
but Jerry described people has come
guzzling markiwood
but yeah so then I go oh hey well that's
fun what was Quintin singing me or
something he goes no I think I got an
idea
cold turkey
it was radio silent so you should text
him how long ago he said that was last
night at about 6:00 okay so that's okay
I would say give it till next week and
then maybe Monday or Tuesday go hey Jer
I'm jonesing for that idea be funny guys
I have an idea for you I mean I started
texting more pictures of Anthony
Bourdain Williams Kate Smith Spade sorry
realize Jerry has a much darker sense of
humor though I got an idea for you you
know Nirvana pictures
that's good stuff you bring people with
you you should possibly choose people to
open for you I have in the past not on
this tour but I have so when you bring
somebody for one gig and then you don't
call him for a while is that just
because you're waiting for the next one
typically means they couldn't cut the
mustard yeah cuz I mean there's a period
of time where you know years ago Amy
Schumer had the gig she got a call for
many more gigs after that Kelsey Cooke
very recently and she got a call for
many more gigs after that I mean the no
call is he said everything was fine yeah
God you scared me now but you know Jim's
going on the road every two seconds
Kelsey Cooke and all that Jerry Dunmore
shows yeah I guess he has right but he's
got a nice rotation of openers stable
stay where your self you got one or two
Tom papa
Mario Joyner you're Hamilton yeah but a
rotation if you don't just do it once
you know I mean in a rotation you have
to get a headed back in at some point
but maybe I'm like a t-shirt with the
wash cycle you know eventually I'll get
back around oh I see maybe the rotation
is just so large
yeah hasn't completed the road she's
volatile for him you think yeah he likes
absolute clean stability stability for
you you're cool you can be clean it's a
struggle cuz you're a pig and it's kind
of hard to you're you're unpredictable
and you Asperger's always say weird [ __ ]
weird she really likes you but he's
probably do I want this [ __ ]
psychopath in front of me every night no
very funny I'm surprised I've lasted
this long let's be honest no you
probably a friend for a long time right
you'll be a friend that got and count on
doing a lot of gig oh yeah no volatile
right I agree with that when he said
we're good but don't do that again that
was his way of saying like we're still
friends and I still think you're funny
maybe we're still hanging but I don't
need somebody running back and forth and
back and forth all over the stage like
it's like you know discoveries child
yeah yeah Brian Hamilton's a better bet
he's very funny is very clean and yeah
and it doesn't seem like it's his first
time in a theater does he wear a suit
oh yeah it's no wild card with him
fifteen just kills killing Hamilton
kills get eight minutes on the bank
killing but yeah I mean that's why
people like you though you're a wild
card you can't and sometimes you can't
you can't tame a wild animal Montez act
like I'm Ari Shaffir over here took my
Kobe and you know having a hideous face
I've just put its doing jokes but you're
Ari Shaffir to Seinfeld
you know I'm Sifl like Ari is Ari to Joe
Rogan we're even Joe's got to be like
whoa right you are that to Jerry
Seinfeld Lauri oh you know the way
you're just like mid-conversation be you
just say like it I'm gay and like it
just keep going right Seinfeld while he
probably acknowledges that's a funny
thing to do it's like that's a little
unpredictable for me